been at it 40 years yeah we're still
finding parts that need to be healed but
it's natural ask these questions of that
place in your body and wait for the
answers to come do you have something
you want to explore
um
[Music]
my guest today is a psychotherapist who
created a very interesting and effective
therapeutic modality called internal
family systems or ifs it's quite a
radical shift in Paradigm you left all
that in the past not realizing you were
locking away exileing your most precious
qualities Dr Richard Schwartz Dick
Schwartz Dick Schwartz ifs yeah it's
incredible big shorts and stuff maybe
some of these parts are bad can we not
label that as something pernicious that
we need to you know override and and and
overcome you can but it hasn't been
working that well he has authored
several books on the subject including
you are the one you've been waiting for
this conversation explores Dr Schwartz's
many parts multiplicity of Mind model
this is a real inner family that we we
all live with it's like your external
family if you neglect them we discuss
how ifs operates to address various
conditions addiction trauma depression
and intimacy this exchange has really
stuck with me I find myself thinking
about myself my parts and why I do what
I do a little bit differently quite
differently as a matter of fact as a
result of this conversation and I
suspect after listening you may as well
so without further Ado this is me and Dr
Richard Schwartz
thank you so much for coming here today
I've been looking forward to this for a
very long time and as I mentioned to you
just prior to recording
um I followed your work for some time uh
you've appeared on a number of podcasts
that I listen to regularly so I'm
familiar with your work but what really
locked in in interest in in in getting
you on the show
was a lunch that I had with with my
friend wrong and Chatterjee I was in
London last year and we met up and had a
meal and he just couldn't stop talking
about ifs and his experience with you
and he's like you got to listen to the
podcast that I did with Richard and he
was raving about how beneficial
um your work your methodology has been
in his own life and uh and uh and so
that that was really kind of like you
know stayed with me and then you know
when I I don't know who reached out but
when you were making yourself available
um I was very glad to you know have the
experience to talk to you today so thank
you well it's very mutual I'm a fan and
I
like I told you I I love what you're
doing for the culture and just happy to
support it and and uh yeah I had a real
a good time with him yeah yeah he's a
good dude indeed yeah so um why don't we
you know start off with the obvious
question which is what is internal
family systems ifs
set the stage and and and explain your
perspective
um on your particular modality of
treating people okay
uh what it is it began as a form of
psychotherapy and it's kind of expanded
to being more like a life practice or a
way of understanding human beings that's
a bit of a different paradigm
and uh
you know the basic assumption is
none of us are unitary personalities
that it's the nature of the mind to have
lots of different what I call Parts but
other people call other names ego States
things like that some personalities
that it's natural
and that those
parts
are all valuable
so I wrote a book no bad parts I've been
doing this 40 years
and I've done it with people who've done
heinous things
and even those parts if you listen to
their secret history will reveal how
they're just stuck in a place in the
past and they're trying to best to
protect the person and they carry this
energy of their perpetrator and so on so
in that sense it's quite a radical shift
in Paradigm right given that the
conventional traditional uh
psychological Paradigm is one of mono
mind as opposed to this multiplicity of
Minds that is kind of the the pathway
into understanding your perspective yeah
and uh when I started talking about
multiplicity the big paradigm
was from what's now called the did uh
literature which would be multiple
personality disorder originally
and they would acknowledge the existence
of these what they called altars
but it was thought that they were
fragments of the broken vase that
you were initially unitary and then
trauma produced all these fragmented
personalities
that took on a life of Their Own
and uh so I've been fighting that
Paradigm for a long time too because for
me
they pre-existed the trauma
and then they got into extreme roles
because of the trauma sometimes just
because they were trying their best to
keep you safe when you were young when
it happened
but
um they they exist they're real it's not
the product of the trauma
so in other words there are there is
this
I guess for lack of a better word
immutable there's an immutable self and
ancillary to that immutable self are all
of these parts that are swimming around
and they're they're in relationship with
each other and they're they're
performing various roles depending upon
things that happen to you Etc
um and and and and your your way of kind
of approaching this and trying to
understand it is premised on on a
systems approach like trying to
understand it like a technology or like
code right so walk me through that
aspect of it and then I kind of want to
understand how you even arrived at this
good idea to begin with
yeah so uh I had a couple big advantages
coming into it one is
I have a PhD in Family Therapy and I was
one of these obnoxious family therapists
that thought we'd discovered the Holy
Grail
and people were mucking around in the
inner World we're wasting their time
because we could change all that by just
reorganizing these family systems
explain sorry sorry to step on you but
like explain family like what does that
mean when you say family families family
systems therapy is
um so if you're working with the acting
out kid for example
you assume that that kid isn't just
whatever diagnosis he carries but that
in some ways he's serving a function in
the family of distracting or he's trying
to protect himself from something that's
happening in the family and that our
assumption was we could reorganize the
family and try to improve
whatever relationships we're producing
as symptoms
and that he would stop doing that and a
lot of times that that worked
but as this family therapist I was
determined to prove that I was in a
department of Psychiatry and
decided to do an outcome study with
eating disorders because my hero at the
time was a guy named Salvador mnuchin
who would use his structural family
therapy with anorexia and claimed a lot
of success so I was gonna
do it with bulimia
and found
to my dismay that we could reorganize
the families just right and still a
bunch of my kids didn't realize they'd
been cured and they kept going how dare
they I know right so this is sort of an
external family systems model right
right organize the people around the
person Afflicted with the condition
you're trying to treat that's right and
and resolve uh with with uh less than
Stellar results is what you're saying
yeah and then out of frustration I began
to ask these kids why are you still
doing it
and they started talking this very weird
language to me at the time
talking about these different parts of
them and how they were doing all this
stuff inside
and so you know an example would be
something happens in my life it triggers
this critic who's brutal and makes me
feel horrible
and that brings up a part that feels
young and empty and alone and worthless
and that feeling is so distressing that
then this binge comes in to get me away
from it
but the the bench triggers the critic
again who's calling me a pig on top of
the other names
and that goes right to the heart of that
empty worthless young one so the the
bench has to come back
I was lucky I had a couple clients who
were extremely articulate about that
whole thing
and at first
because I didn't know from Parts at
first I thought these kids are sicker
than I thought maybe they have multiple
personality disorder
and then I listened inside myself and oh
my god I've got them too and I've got
this critic and I can binge on food
sometimes and other things and I have a
piece of worthlessness in there
and so then I calmed down and got really
curious and
just started to ask a lot of questions
about how do they relate to each other
and how does it work in there
and you know I was lucky that I hadn't
studied any psychoanalytic or
psychodynamic therapies so I did I came
with fresh eyes right like a beginner's
mind I was just going to say that so I
really had to trust what they were
saying about the phenomena
and that's partly why this is different
I think than a lot of things both that
and the systems frame where rather than
just focusing on one part trying to
figure it out
I was really trying to understand the
way this whole network operated as a
system
and that's what we go to change we're
trying to change the whole network
rather than just one at a time right I
think it is a universal condition of
Being Human that we understand we have
different voices in our head and you
know I I you know I I don't think you
have to be afflicted by anything
particular or acute to relate to the
idea that sometimes you feel worthless
sometimes you feel better than somebody
else sometimes you feel judgmental or
hard on yourself in a way that you you
know is disproportionate whatever's
happening or you know self-esteem like
the the list is endless right so within
that
there's this inner monologue that we all
have about the relationship between the
person we think we are or the person we
wish we were and how that relates to all
of these other you know kind of voices
that are criticizing us or urging us to
do this or that which either are in
parallel or orthogonal to that you know
sense of of who we think we are or want
to be exactly
and my contention is these aren't just
Little Voices or thought patterns or
emotions those are the manifestations of
these parts
but if I were to have you focus on one
of them
exclusively for a second
and get curious about it and just ask
you'd find out that it's a full range
personality that really has a lot to
tell you but besides the little thought
it's giving you and that it's stuck in
an extreme role
often if it's an extreme part
because of something that happened in
your childhood maybe or uh yeah and that
through trial and error over time we
found out how to help all these parts
change and to actually leave their
extreme roles and become who they're
designed to be so that's the goal of the
model was there yeah was there like a
light bulb moment though in terms of how
you started to think about the lattice
work or the the relationship between all
of these like how does the systems
because it just seems so murky and and
hard to get your hands around like what
is actually going on like how do you
overlay this
um with some sense of organization or or
kind of I don't know
um
uh you know animating kind of unifying
principle
you know it's really interesting because
as we talk about it it seems murky but
if I was to have you focus inside you
would start oh there is this one over
here and there's this other one over
here and it becomes far less murky you
can actually map it all out and we
actually help people do that
um and yeah the
it's just so rare for people to do it
people do it through mindfulness
and they'll notice their thoughts and
emotions but
for me it's not compassionate to watch
suffering beings parade by possibly
so this is mindfulness plus it's like
get mindful
and then go to them and help them and
hold them and show them you care about
them
and they will start to relax and
you know most it turned out after many
years of doing this that most of these
parts are quite young and yet they're
still running your life it's like in
Family Therapy we had a concept we call
parentified Child
a child who was forced to be a parent
because the parents had abdicated
and couldn't handle it but still tried
to do it
and many of these parts are like that
they're they're much younger they're
often like I said
Frozen in time and in bad times in your
life where they got stuck
they think you're still five years old
they think they still have to protect
you the way they did back then
and they carry something I'm going to
call burdens that carry extreme beliefs
and emotions that came into you in that
moment
and attached to these parts and drive
them like a virus and the coronavirus
act actually
so a lot of the healing is helping them
let go of these extreme loose emotions
get him out of where they're stuck in
the past
I want to dig into that in a in a very
specific way in particular the various
roles that these parts take on and why
they take them on but you mentioned
mindfulness and this idea of mindfulness
plus like mindfulness is where your
presence and in a in a place of of
awareness and noticing so you can be
aware and non-judgmental as these you
know kind of ideas or voices are kind of
passing through your Consciousness and
depending upon the modality of of
mindfulness that you practice or at
least in certain strains of of
meditation there's a different idea at
play which is the more Buddhist notion
of of no mind right like this idea that
that you know in a non-dualistic sense
like there is no self there is just
Consciousness right and that is very
different from what you're saying which
is there is a self there is this self
that lies within us like this kernel I
guess with all these orbiting you know
asteroids and planets that sometimes
Collide into the self that are the
respective parts so
before we get into the parts
is it is it the case from your
perspective that that that that you know
I said immutable before like we all have
some self within us that is unchanging
since birth and is that the case for
every person and how did you arrive at
that notion yeah so
and and just to clarify what Buddhists
call no self or like you said no mine
is what I call self
the it's semantic yeah now we're getting
conf it's going to get confusing I'll
just try to explain it real quick
so what you find and this is what I'm
about to describe is that as you get
these parts to separate inside it
releases this person who
you know when I say what what is that
that knows how to heal your parts you
would say well that's me that's not
these parts
so I came to call that the self for that
reason
but what the Buddhists call Self is
really these parts so as they open space
it's who's left which is the emptiness
that's so full so it's really the same
idea really yeah
um
trying to understand that I think I
understand what you're saying
um
I think we all uh like if we spend
enough time
looking at somebody who behaved badly
and that person was willing to open up
about why they you know do what they do
um that you will develop an
understanding like it will make sense if
you understood the you know like the
their life history and the context in
which you know that behavior developed
over time it would all be very black and
white right like it's it's very much in
line with Gabor mate's work I think and
I think you've done some stuff with him
like there seems to be a lot of
parallels here in the sense that
um it's about really looking at the why
behind the symptom that's right like why
is this person doing this tracing it
back to something that happened in in
their childhood Etc
um to try to make sense of it rather
than let's let's just malign it or or
repress it or pretend it doesn't exist
and focus on you know moving forward and
and these other behaviors like
strengthening you know the more positive
behaviors yeah which is sort of the
culture's approach to these things and a
lot of therapies too
so this is quite the opposite it's again
saying they're all good
um they're forced into these extreme
roles
but if you just take the time to start
to get curious and listen to them
they'll tell you their secret histories
of how they got hurt so it isn't like I
have to figure out where it happened in
the past
I'm working with you
and you're working with maybe your angry
part
not that you have one but and it's it's
in there okay and I'm having you focus
on it and asking it about itself
and also asking what it's afraid would
happen if it didn't get so angry
sometimes
and answering that
you would learn that it it really is
desperately trying to protect you and
that it's protecting some other part of
you that's quite young and vulnerable
and we would negotiate permission to go
to that one and there's a process by
which we would heal that
but all of that I would be doing when
you were in what I call Self so to come
back to your original question which is
how did I Stumble onto that
so I was learning about these parts
and I'm a family therapist so as I took
started taking them more seriously
um I'm trying to get my client to relate
to them differently and
it took a while for me to get that they
aren't what they seemed because
at first I thought the critic was and
the field still does some kind of
internalized parental voice the binge
was some kind of out of control impulse
when you think of that way it makes
sense to fight with a critic or ignore
it or to try and control the binge
but if you think of them as I learned
ultimately
that they're just really good parts that
got forced into these Extreme Rules and
they're just trying their best to keep
you safe
then you come to them with curiosity
first and ultimately compassion
and you can wind up honoring them for
their service like you might the
military these protective parts and they
love that and as you do that and change
these internal relationships
they'll start to change too and but to
get back to the original story so once I
got hip to the fact they aren't what
they seem they deserve to be listened to
I'm trying to get my client to do that
and
are
so maybe I'm having my client talk to
that critic
inside
and it's going pretty well
but suddenly she's furious with the
critic
and it reminded me of family sessions
where I'm I'm trying to have two people
maybe a critical mother and a teenage
girl
talk to each other about their
relationship it's going okay suddenly
the girl gets furious with the mother
we were taught to look around the room
and see if somebody isn't subtly
siding with the girl against the mother
and often maybe the father is and so we
were taught to get that person out of
her range of vision
and create a better boundary around the
two of them and that she the girl would
settle down and they would have a decent
conversation
and I thought maybe the same thing's
happening in this inner World maybe as
my clients trying to get to know this
critic
the part who hates the critic has come
in is doing the talking
it's hard to say to Clarence
can you find the one who's so angry the
critic and get it to just relax in there
until we're done just ask it to give us
a break here
and to my amazement clients could do
that pretty readily most of them
and when they did it I'd say now how do
you feel the CR toward the critic
it would be some version of I'm just
curious why it calls me names
the seconds earlier they hated it or
maybe they were terrified of it the
simple Act of getting these parts to
open space
seemed to release this other person
who Not only was just curious but also
was calm and confident and even
compassionate sometimes like I'm sorry
that it has to do this right to get them
to get that self to disengage with those
parts that are impulsing words and
behavior that are non-productive to the
the kind of healing path that you're
trying to get them on yeah and and the
the big deal about ifs is that suddenly
this other person that I came to call
the self would emerge spontaneously
it wasn't like we had to build up the
muscle of compassion or anything like
that it was really just opening space
and it was uncovered it just came out
and then in that state
the dialogue with the critic or any
other part would go well because
what now this is 40 years later and
thousands of people later using this and
we can pretty safely say that that self
is in everybody
can't be damaged
knows how to heal
and is just beneath the surface of these
parts such that when they open space it
pops out hmm
the untarnished self that has always
been there since
conception or whenever you believe
Consciousness arises
that then gets painted in various Colors
by Dent of the way these parts kind of
emerge over time but what I like about
it is
the non-pathologizing kind of approach
like instead of naming these things with
you know terms and words that make us
feel bad about ourselves or you know are
in alignment with some kind of diagnosis
it's understanding that all these parts
are actually good faith actors like
they're they're operating
in what they believe to be the best
interest of the self but they're out of
they're just out of alignment like
they're extreme in their role or because
of the interplay between you know
different different parts creates a
non-optimal situation for that self to
be expressed in the way that it could be
otherwise yeah
um like most these parts got their roles
when you were too young to protect
yourself
and so they think you're not able to do
that and so they have to do it for you
and so as one of the things we do often
is is just I would have you ask that
angry one why how old it thinks you are
and you'll get a single digit most of
the time
and then I'll say just update it a
little bit and see how it reacts and
sometimes they're amazed that you're you
know a grown man who can protect himself
now
and can take care of them they don't
have to take care of you in that same
way yeah they they didn't get the
newsletter update no exactly they're
still operating like you're a
five-year-old right and they're still
frozen in time back in that scene right
so
so that just
um you know one of the goals is to help
these parts
revert to their naturally valuable
States
second goal is for them to trust self as
a leader to learn they don't have to do
it all because there's this other person
in there that can do it for them
um yeah I've got a lot of questions
about that but but let's get into the
various roles that these parts can play
you have a couple categories to help us
understand that Exiles managers and and
firefighters so can you walk me through
yeah so again I'm a systems guy and as
I'm hearing about all this I'm looking
for distinctions and patterns that's
what systems people do and the big
distinction that emerged immediately was
between these parts that
uh we're very vulnerable and hurt
and then the parts that protected them
so that's really the big distinction
and as I got to know that uh the first
class other sisters would call Inner
children so they're they're young and
sensitive
but when they're not hurt they're
playful and loving and open and creative
and wonderful
and we love them I mean we don't really
know them but we love having them around
but they're the most sensitive parts so
they're the ones who get hurt the most
by the slings and arrows or by the bad
parenting or by the traumas
and once they do they take on what I
call burdens like emotional pain or
worthlessness and shame or
Terror from the event and now they're
not so much fun to be around because
they have the power to overwhelm us and
pull us back into those memories and
make it so we can't function very well
so we kind of naturally try to lock them
away
and in her basements or a business and
try our best to stay away from them
and everybody around us tells us to do
that because this is a rugged
individualist culture
and so you probably got the message many
times just move on don't think don't
look back you can't change what happened
and so you did you left all that in the
past thinking you were just moving on
from the memories or the emotions not
realizing you were locking away exiling
your most precious qualities just
because they got hurt and so once you
get a lot of Exiles like that
you feel more delicate the world seems
more dangerous because so many things
could trigger them
and again if they get triggered it's
like flames of emotion
overwhelm you and take you out
so you have this sort of unconscious
fear that drives you to avoid those
types of situations so that you're not
back in that place yeah what's
interesting about that though you use
the word Exile like when I was trying to
understand what you meant by that
um
you know for me like trying to recollect
some of those incidents in in my own
life and how I you know moved forward or
failed to move forward in in the
healthiest way
um I almost feel like those parts are
not necessarily in Exile but perhaps too
present like what I've actually exiled
are all the memories or experiences
where
you know somebody made me feel good or
affirmed me or told me that I was worthy
or that I should keep going or you know
gave me encouragement or or mentorship
and instead you know you kind of lock
onto those negative experiences that
occur and you create narratives around
them that end up driving your behavior
well into adulthood so have I not just
haven't I exiled like all the good
things and and overly you know
emphasized these you know sort of
you know a few incidents and and turn
them into much bigger deals than they
should be yeah there are parts that do
that so what I was calling the critic
has a habit of doing that and for
various reasons we can get into that it
doesn't want you to feel good about
yourself and so it will lock away any
information that counters its narrative
like you said of who you are and how bad
you are or how nobody likes you or how
dangerous the world is
and but if I were to have you focus on
that part
get curious about it ask what it's
afraid would happen if it didn't do that
job
you there's one of three different
answers you commonly get either it's
trying to keep you small so that you
don't shine and get hurt
or it's trying to motivate you like you
said to work harder and do better and
given your life that's probably the one
or um
I can't remember the third but yeah well
I think I checked both those boxes yeah
yeah yeah for sure well I mean we can
you know we can get into all my all my
voices and all my in all my parts but
certainly uh there is there is uh you
know a voice that's telling me you're
not you know you're not you're not good
enough and you and you have and the the
love and acceptance that you seek uh can
only be earned through accomplishments
and you know external validation Etc of
course like you never quite get there
you can chase that forever and I have my
theories about why I feel that way
um but that critic is is definitely you
know powerful and I had the same part I
came out of my family
um I'm the oldest of six boys and my
father was a very prominent physician
researcher
and I was supposed to be that and I had
80d so I wasn't a good student and it
drove him crazy
and and three of my brothers are big
time physician researcher types
and so I came out of that relationship
with a lot of burdens of worthlessness
because he gave me that message directly
or indirectly many times
and with that burden of worthlessness
the part who carries that would be the
Exile that I tried to get away from all
the time
but there is also a Critic who is saying
echoing his voice
and is
trying to to goad me into achieving to
counter the worthlessness and to
constantly get more and more
achievements and ifs wouldn't exist if
that wasn't true because right I
wouldn't that's what makes it so
difficult to overcome right because this
is on some level of superpower it's an
unsustainable one and it's not a healthy
one right but to ask somebody to let go
of that or disentangle themselves from
that is a threat you know that probably
activates another part which is saying
if you let go of that then this whole
house of cards is going to cave on top
of itself because this is what you know
this is the this is what you're you know
this is where your drive that's right
and I totally bought into that until
various circumstances made me actually
do the work
and I'm here to tell you that
um it's probably been 20 years
but that critic has got a totally
different job that Exile worthlessness
is all unburdened
and I'm still cooking it's not it didn't
yeah yeah and actually what job does a
Critic have now let me let me finish
actually it's much more effective
because I'm a much better leader I'm
leading from what we call self now
and so part of what happened was you
know I that critic leaks out toward
other people
and so I when I became the leader of a
community
it wasn't helpful I was alienating
people and polarizing and so I was lucky
I had people come and say you you got to
do your work
and so having done that now the critic
you got to walk your own walk you gotta
walk around walk yeah and the critic is
now
he helps me discern what's good and
valuable and like this podcast and what
I should stay away from he's just a
discerner
and the former uh worthless part the
shame part
now is a playful little guy and so I
don't ever anymore I can say this
honestly it drives my wife crazy because
um she feels like I should yell at
myself a lot more than I do
but I really don't I don't hear that
nagging critical voice anymore
um
the shame uh piece I think is is huge
for a lot of people it certainly is with
me and it's you know on my list of
of you know voices in my head deep shame
for things I've done in the past that I
can't change that I'll fixate on
um and how that relates to you know all
these other
aspects of of you know all these other
parts in my personality you know that
love is conditional and based on
accomplishment Excellence is mandatory
you're never going to be good enough
um and when you fall short
it's more than guilt it is a feeling of
of Shame like that you uh that that
drives that sense of worthlessness
um and you know in my case it links up
with you know an imposter syndrome meets
you know perfectionism
control issues and and uh and also like
a big you know big part is is is fear
like Dread like you should be very
afraid catastrophe is just around the
corner it's only a matter of time you
know before they find out that you don't
know what you're doing and they're gonna
pull the mic away from you and lock you
up for good yeah
I appreciate your disclosure about all
that and
uh what I can say is that you're not
alone there's many people who and I was
that way and
shame is a is a real motivator because
shame and worthlessness especially when
you're a child and you get that message
is terrifying because we're born as
children knowing
that if my parent doesn't like me and
thinks I'm worthless I'm gonna die and
many children all over the world die
because their parents don't value them
so whenever you have that burden it's
going to be very motivating to get away
from
or it's gonna you know shut you down so
you don't even try
so you're right it's a shame is a really
um powerful burden yeah
so in addition to the the Exiles we also
have the managers and the firefighters
and you know I I tend to kind of look at
these things through my own experience
with addiction and Recovery as just kind
of a operating you know example of how
to illustrate this but it seems to me
that yes I've you know I've exiled these
certain parts of myself
um and you know the firefighters are are
the kind of extreme parts that flare up
when you get really threatened in a very
particular way and in the case of of
substance abuse that turns into you know
kind of like the binges that you were
talking about right that allow you to
disassociate with whatever pain that
that scenario or situation was producing
generally unconsciously in the person
and then recovery is sort of a process
of having the manager take over and get
everybody in line so that you can
function as a you know responsible human
being in the world well that is the
current state of the art of addiction
work is to
get the manager to sit on the
firefighter as well as the exile
I'm trying to change that because
I'm trying to help people in the
addictions world
actually listen to and value the
firefighters
even though they've ruined their lives
they're really just trying to protect
and then learn what they protect and
heal that and then help those
firefighters out of their extreme roles
are rather than trying to control them
all the time because
you know either
you don't succeed and you just feel
worse and worse because you're not
you're still binging you can't do your
recovery
or you do succeed
and then you become something of a dry
drunk who's got to be careful all the
time
to not have that get triggered again
and
so the alternative is to go to these
firefighting addictive parts
and like I said learn about what they're
protecting and heal that and then they
so they they change they take on new
roles
so it's a different Paradigm for
understanding addiction yeah it is uh
and it's it's uh it's provocative for me
to hear that because I am you know a
product of of traditional 12-step and
um it's benefited me in miraculous ways
so maybe I can push back a little bit
and then you can give me your your
response to that
um I think there's a difference between
between recovery and abstinence and the
dry drunk scenario is a is a you know
would fall into the into the abstinence
category but if you're properly working
these these tools
um you are uh you know you you are then
moving to a place of of peace with
yourself yeah
um that I think transcends that that dry
drunkness and and you know allows you to
function I totally in your yeah like so
you you there is like a
um it's more than a Armistice with your
parts like there is a there is a a
relationship with them of of
understanding I guess right yeah I
overstated my case because I'm really
trying to bring something different but
uh 12 step is great at certain things I
heard you talk to somebody recently
about how it de-shames people just being
able to disclose
what you're feeling ashamed of and have
a group be very accepting of that and
talk about their own
so there is a certain amount of healing
your Exiles that takes place in that
context
and then that makes the job of the
firefighter that much easier I mean less
intense it can actually Stand Down
better
and it also gets the critic off your
back who's
before you did the 12-step was saying
you're the only one you're the only one
who can't control it you're just bad
and now sees that it's so common and so
yes I there's a lot of benefit to 12
step I didn't mean to right so is there
is there uh a logic in in your approach
in combination with 12-step yes
application is sort of like mindfulness
plus sort of 12-step Plus on top of it
like they're they can work in parallel
that's right
I'd say the only difference
uh at least in the beginning is
to change the view of the addictive part
to really
listen to it and honor it for its
service like you might the military
rather than see it as as the enemy
right to try to understand this was a
this was an aspect of or I was going to
say an aspect of yourself but you see it
this is a part that is being activated
to protect you in a certain situation
because it felt that you were under
threat and with that we can be
compassionate about why that you know
that that that part you know flares up
and it's firefighter role from time to
time because it it really did have your
best interest at heart and it didn't
realize that it was actually harming you
yeah so
as you start to do that and you change
your relationship with that part
and even before you've healed what
drives a just letting it know you you
understand it better and you can see how
it's really trying to help even though
it's not sometimes and that it's stuck
in the past
just that shift in relationship the part
starts to relax a lot and then if you
get triggered and you have that big
impulse right away
you can just remind it I know you're
trying to take care of me right now but
just trust me I don't need that right
now and and you'll find a lot more
cooperation inside
because you have this sort of loving
relationship with the part that
ordinarily you were really you know
afraid of or angry at
feels very esoteric I'm imagining myself
in a situation of vulnerability where
suddenly there's an overwhelming you
know kind of craving or desire and as
they say and you know the parlance of
12-step like the Train's already pulled
out of the station like you're already
in a crisis at that point like I don't
know that a conversation with that part
at that point would be adequate uh
mute that incredibly powerful overriding
impulse it wouldn't in the current state
of the art so
but if you've worked on it and you've
built this whole new relationship with
it and it knows you now and it knows it
doesn't have to protect you in that same
way
then you have that that c word choice in
the moment much more than you you do
when it just acts automatically and and
uh does its its job that way yeah I
think one qualitative difference between
your approach and 12-step would be uh
the the value in peering into your past
and trying to understand it like there
is this sort of premise
in in traditional recovery models that
it doesn't necessarily matter why you
are an alcoholic or became an alcoholic
like you can
cast your gaze into your past and and
try to Grapple with that and maybe you
come up with an answer maybe you don't
but right here today uh this is what you
need to worry about and here are the
things that you can do very practical
tools that can keep you on the rails and
and move you in a better direction as
opposed to your perspective which is
it's all about what happened to you in
the past and rather than than you know
averting your gaze there being curious
about it and really exploring it helps
you to have not only a better
understanding of the driving forces uh
that led you to behave in this way but
to make peace with them and to be in in
relationship with them uh in in an
honoring way almost right yeah so that
they don't act out yeah and to
what I call unburdened these parts that
are stuck in the past in
and you know in contrast to maybe
psychoanalysis or other kinds of more
cerebral Therapies
I wouldn't be having you try to figure
out and go through your history from a
rational place and try to identify the
key trauma in your life
I would have you focus on
the pain or the shame or the terror or
the sense of rejection or or you know
just the what you described earlier the
part of you that feels like why would
anybody want me
and I would have you find it in your
body
and I would have you just ask these
questions of that place in your body and
wait for the answers to come rather than
think of the answer
so it's a very different approach
and people
start to see themselves often as a child
stuck in a bad situation in the past or
a whole series of bad situations
and then
I would say how do you feel toward that
boy
and
if you were himself you'd say I feel
sorry for him I want to help him
a lot of times you'd say well he's a
wimp I you know I just he was too weak
he shouldn't have gotten hurt like that
so I said can we get that part to give
us a break and so we can actually help
him and get him out of where he's stuck
so it's it's a much more limbic kind of
emotional uh experience than trying to
figure it out from this cerebral part
yeah is is that how is that different
from
inner child work is it different just
because you're recognizing all of these
parts and their interplay that's one of
the differences
is I'm seeing this as an ecology and
so for example before I would have you
go to that boy
I would have you work with the part that
doesn't want you to go there and I was
afraid you'd be overwhelmed by what he
feels and I would spend time
going over those fears and I would be
addressing those fears and getting
permission before I went
because I learned the hard way that if I
just had you go to that inner child
and you did feel overwhelmed
these protectors will backlash and
they'll they'll make you feel terrible
and ruin our relationship
so that's how it's an ecologically
sensitive model
um
I'm both working with these protectors
beforehand
and getting permission and then having
them come in to see the change after
afterwards so that's all one difference
the other bigger difference is in what I
call Self so that
yeah there's a lot of people that do
inner child work
they're the one the therapist is doing
the talking to the inner child and the
child is forming a relationship with a
therapist that can be healing I'm not
trying to say it's not healing
but for me it's better if yourself is
the one to take care of that child
and get it out of where it's stuck so
the child comes to trust you
as uh it's the attachment figure or you
know the good parent inside rather than
me right right
um
how does this operate in other contexts
Beyond addiction I mean I know there's a
there's a variety of of of
different conditions in which you've had
a lot of success
so maybe we could talk about like let's
just talk about depression like how is
that have you have you noticed because
you're a systems guy like okay in
addiction here's what it kind of always
looks like with everyone between the
cacophony of these various parts and the
roles they're taking on like what does
it look like with depression with
depression so again you've got an exile
who's very hurt or very sad and
uh the protector is trying to keep you
away from it and depression usually
there's a part that kind of numbs you
out and flattens you out so you don't
have much affect
and it's really really afraid of that
Exile it's afraid of of the pain that
would overwhelm you
and so it makes you kind of apathetic
and inert a lot of the time
and then you've got the critic who's
nailing you for being depressed and why
can't you get over it why can't you just
get out there and so it's it's a version
of that and
uh yeah we have a lot of good luck with
depression
so untangling that knot involves a
variety of conversations with these
various parts and and getting them to
retreat or chill out basically yeah
um getting them to buy in you know I'm
what I call a hope Merchant so if I went
to that flattening part of you
I would say You Know Rich ask what it's
afraid would happen if it lets you feel
much
and it would say you'd be overwhelmed
and you'd be pulled into the abyss and I
can't let that happen
okay if we could heal that so it wasn't
such a threat would you have to keep him
so flat
and the part would say no but I don't
think you can do that
if I thought you could do it I wouldn't
be doing this because they none of them
like their jobs
I'm so could you give me a chance to
prove that we can because we can heal
that part so you don't have to do this
job you can be freed up to do something
entirely different do you then uh give
give those parts a new job like a
specific new job like don't you have to
direct that energy into something
specific no I would say Rich ask this
flattening part what it would like to do
instead if it really didn't have to do
that
you'd be amazed at the answer it's often
the opposite it wants to get you out and
give you a lot of Life yeah so I don't
have to assign any jobs we just
where the concept is
they're all valuable they got stuck in
these roles and we're allowing them to
return to their naturally valuable
States the more I learn about this work
that you do and the more I'm I'm
cognizant of the various parts and
how they're impulsing me in in various
ways
the more I realize you can kind of see
it in other people too especially people
you know well like when they're behaving
in a certain manner if you know them
well enough you can almost see like oh
that that's that piece that's not really
their that their self their their
activated right now for this reason or
that reason so I can imagine that
there's a lot of
benefit in in uh in the context of
intimacy here right this new book that
you have um you you are the one is
really all you're the one you've been
waiting for is really kind of all about
that like in a couples therapy context
having uh a shared understanding of each
other's parts and how they how they
function
can be extremely beneficial in creating
healthier communication because we're
all anybody who's been in a relationship
like you you get your buttons get pushed
or you you know you say something they
say something and then you're reacting
to the various parts as opposed to
seeing the self you know beneath all the
activity that's kind of
you know hanging over the whole dynamic
that goes sideways yeah exactly so
on a good day you know I'm a guy and I
trigger my wife and she's Italian so
she's got this
big Angry part
and
um it's startling to me because it would
remind me of my father when he would get
so angry and it would originally hurt
these little
parts that were hurt by my father and so
I would come back with try to match that
energy and we would have these big
fights
and it wasn't always you know she's
probably gonna listen to this so I I
want to clarify I wasn't always her that
started
um
but now both of us can kind of say okay
I can see she's in that part
and when you're in what I call self it's
like you have X-ray vision
as you can see behind the protector to
the Exile that's driving the protector
you can actually have compassion in the
face of
the anger and if I can stay in self and
not take the bait and not you know
because self is contagious
and protectors are contagious so if I
react from a protective part
it's going to escalate and we're both
going to get more and more extreme
if I can like I said see the pain that's
driving her
stay in self
and speak in this very different voice
she'll calm down pretty quick
and again I want to make us clear it's
both ways and
yeah so that's one very valuable aspect
of ifs and couples
but let me go back to something I was
saying earlier because most of us come
into relationships
with this exiled part that feels
worthless and is looking to
our partner or feels terrified is
looking to our partner to take care of
that part of it right right right and
our partners can't do that and our
partner at some point will trigger those
same Parts in the same way
and we might even be looking
for a partner who resembles the person
we got it from because we're still
desperate to get Dad to tell me I'm
valuable rather than so somebody
resembles that and they're they love me
oh that's so you know I just feel
wonderful after I'd feel that from
somebody but then
she yells at me like that I didn't oh
I'm back
so she can't be the one it's got to be
somebody else out there that I gotta
find
so
what I try to do is uh you turn in in
couples Focus so that each partner
becomes what I call the the primary
caretaker or attachment figure for their
own Parts which frees up the partner to
be the secondary caretaker because most
all of us have that reversed we want our
partner to take care of our parts
or we want some Affair to do it or some
you know that it's got a come from an
external person but if you because we
don't want to take responsibility for
our own [__] come on who wants to do
that right it's much more fun to get
into a relationship with somebody and
project onto that person a a fantasy or
an idealized version of who you think
they are who you would like them to be
and then charge them with the
responsibility of healing all of your
wounds right and when two people are
doing that simultaneously it's
combustible right
yeah so it becomes tricky I would
imagine when you have couples come in
two people you have you know it's a very
complicated knot untie and to you know
gain some level of clarity and then
beyond that once you have that
understanding those those buttons are so
deeply ingrained right like uh
to not react when it gets pushed in the
way that you have historically your
entire life
I feel like in intellectual
understanding of the dynamic will only
get you part of the way there like I
think you know mindfulness and
meditation play a big role in just
giving you that extra pause so you can
kind of calculate your environment a
little bit better and calibrate your
your response
um
but that identification piece that
you're talking about like oh that's the
critic or that's the this and that you
know that's what's operating here yeah
I'm on a good day
we get into it we both say okay time out
we get away from each other
we both go inside we find the parts that
we're doing the talking
we try to get them to tell us about the
parts they're protecting
we go in and let them know
we get that that felt bad
but let me handle this you guys don't
have to handle it so from self I'm
saying that mm-hmm
and I feel the shift I feel
that Rush of anger just kind of separate
and I'll I'll say I'll you know we'll
talk to you later
let me go back and so I go back in a
very different place and she does too
and things that used to take days to get
over
take out you know right yeah sure yeah
yeah
um how do you work with somebody
who has compartmentalized that that
piece of themselves
so so completely such that you know the
request to bring it into the light or be
in conversation with it is is equal is
almost like a death threat right like
the like they're holding on so tightly
to this thing that makes them you know
they think makes them who they are and
to relinquish control or to have a
different relationship with whatever it
is makes it it literally feels like
you're going to die right because that
is part and parcel of how they've
constructed their identity to keep
themselves safe that's right
and again you're using pronoun day but
it's just a part so there is a part
that's been running their life and
thinks it's them
and is very attached to being in charge
and so the idea that there are other
parts is very threatening to it the idea
that it's not who rich is
uh like you said it can be terrifying
like they're going to die if they really
even look at that
so there are some clients like that that
come in
and I'm very gently just connecting with
them I'm not bringing up parts I'm just
helping them trust that it's a safe
environment
and that at some point
I might say something like
you know I noticed that uh there's a
part of you that really has gotten you
where you where you are now and it's
been terribly
valuable in many ways and I'll bet it's
really tiring because I I bet it's just
constantly striving and working and
uh we we love that part so valuable and
it's done such a good job but just check
and see if it might want a little bit of
a break and
and might want to check around and see
if it's if it's totally alone in there
or if there might be other
parts of you or even uh you who could be
helping it
so it's a kind of a sales pitch really
yeah but to do it in a very gentle
non-judgmental non-pathologizing way
loving way we love this instead of you
know that thing that you do is hurting
everybody around you all the time like
that doesn't work you know and that
that's a a relic of the 12-step movement
too where you're to confront people
about how how much damage their activity
is cost and that's that's a big mistake
in general I mean sometimes it works
that like shakes people out of there but
a lot of times people just get more
entrenched in their protectors
yeah that's interesting I mean there is
you know a core piece obviously is is
the is the inventory right which nobody
really tells you what you kind of can't
write but you're meant to go on this
inward journey to you know really you
know tabulate your behavior over time
um
and I think there's a lot of value in
that because it does SNAP you out of
whatever identity mode you're in about
who you think you are and and sheds
light on the reality of how you actually
behave and that allows you to then see
how that impacts other people and then
you know in lockstep with that you make
your amends into the world that's right
so explain to me what's missing in that
piece is it the sense that it's like
there's a there's a harshness to it or
you know what would you you know there
can be I think there's 12-step
approaches that aren't harsh that really
just do try to do that inventory from a
mindful place and not the shame isn't so
so involved in a
um and even if you do it softly
I mean a lot of times the addiction is a
way to stay away from even looking at
all the stuff you've done in your life
so just
pushing somebody to go back and look
can be very very triggering for them and
bring forth all kinds of Shame so
um I don't have an argument with what
you just described it's more uh
when somebody's in denial
the aggressive approach to that denying
part rather than I can see there's a
part that doesn't want to look at any of
this let's get to know that part and see
what it's afraid would happen and then I
would reassure the part that there's a
lot we can handle and I'd be right there
to handle help it with that do you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah I understand
that and and it's all founded on this
idea that there are no bad parts or I
think the title of one of the other
books
um
having a compassionate relationship with
all of these parts but
is there an argument to be had that that
maybe some of these parts are bad like
what about the the person who has the
part in them that that makes them you
know go shoot up a school or you know
perpetrate a a violent crime on another
individual like yeah is it your argument
that we should have compassion for that
piece and try to understand why it it
drove the self to act out in that way or
can we not label that as something
pernicious that we need to you know
override and and and overcome
you can but it hasn't been working that
well so
I believed that okay maybe these critics
are good and maybe these binging parts
are good but what about those kinds of
people that you just described
and to test that I consulted to a
treatment center for offenders sex
offenders
for a number of years and worked with a
lot of those perpetrators and we would
find the perpetrating part
and they of course felt totally ashamed
of it and so we had to work a lot to the
point where they could get curious about
it
and then start asking these same kind of
questions and it would show them scenes
in their childhood when they were being
perpetrated
not necessarily in the same way
and that this part decided I've got to
protect this kid
looked around the room and said who has
power in this room it's the person who's
hurting me
I'm going to take in that energy
to try and protect
the kid from that parent and then gets
stuck with this this per this desire to
hurt people the desire to to hurt little
kids even
uh get stuck with that burden
and
then you know the person goes into life
and tries to keep it at Bay and lock it
up and it just gets more extreme right
right that that tends not to work right
yeah so the
point of all that is once I got that
that's when I could start saying okay
maybe there are no bad parts and I would
go to other you know I've been in
prisons I've been working with murderers
I've been is that does that work have
you noticed whether that works in a in a
case of of true sociopathy or somebody
who is you know uh completely lacking in
empathy altogether is it is it a case of
understanding why they lack empathy you
know getting to know those parts
them to a place where their self can
experience empathy again yes yes it's
the case that's revolutionary in terms
of how that that contradicts it's very
revolutionary and
um it's it's if you see them as a
sociopath
you're going to have one response if you
say oh there's a part that protects them
that doesn't let them feel anything or
care anything about anybody and just
tries to get whatever they want even if
it's destructive to other people and
it's a protector and let's get to know
it and see where it's stuck in the past
and help it which is what I've been
doing with a lot of these kinds of
people I know that this modality is is
you know like we said you know kind of
at odds with traditional methods uh so
what is the like how is this being
received in the the broader you know
scientific community in in your field
has that changed I mean there there is
because it's so different and what
you're proposing is you know at odds
with so many so many of the the kind of
principles it's very radical and
uh you know I told you this is our 40th
anniversary of the beginning of it and
so for probably 30 years I labored in
obscurity and I got attacked by those
kinds of people and
seen as dangerous and uh for whatever
reason the last decade it's caught fire
and I don't really know why I've tried
to figure it out
not as much like I was in Academia I was
in the department of psychiatry
and then tried to present there and got
attacked and just decided okay I'm going
to go Grassroots
so since then I've been the last 30
years I've just been trying to bring it
to
therapists
and uh and now it's everywhere now
I don't know why it's being embraced
yeah and is there a different narrative
within that more traditional culture
that's changing or is it there's still
resistance no it's not
no they're still very wedded to the DSM
and seeing all these things as diseases
or disorders and it's still very
simplistic in other words diagnose
prescribe
without uh you know understanding like
when you like what is the the emotional
experience of of diagnosing a patient
when they hear that diagnosis and and
and what that does to someone's you know
awareness of like who they are and what
they're capable of and what they're not
capable of
well um you know if some diagnoses
people attached to and they feel like
okay I've got this condition that's why
I'm doing the stuff
and it's a relief in a sense and
some of their 12-step does that you know
you're an addict and
all that
uh but it doesn't really help you change
your relationship with the parts that
are making you do this it just kind of
it helps you with your Shame about it
but you still feel like a broken person
you feel like there's something wrong
with you
and that uh it's not you know very
pessimistic about changing it other than
medication
or
um
20 years of talk therapy
and and your perspective there's there's
there isn't that immutability obviously
in in the Diagnostics yeah
these Diagnostics these diagnostic
categories just represent clusters of
protectors usually that
you know they're pretty good
descriptions of common clusters of
protectors but that's all they are
and and so instead
uh we go to the protectors and we start
to
to help them trust they don't have to
keep doing this
how does the the ego work within all of
this the ego as we sort of
conventionally understand it
um
is there a locus of that in this model
or you think differently around that
like explain your yeah so what people
traditionally call the ego for me is a
cluster of little managers they're the
parts that you'll most identified with
some you know some think they are you
like we were saying
and they they run your life and they're
you know the voices in your head that
are trying to figure out when you're in
a dilemma which way to go it's often
these two different managers trying to
both trying to protect but an opposite
way
so that's what both uh psychology and
also spirituality
see the ego as as often a past you know
that gets in the way and
are
and so I'm trying to also
bring this compassionate awareness of
the ego because it's the parts of you
that that jumped into those roles to
just manage your life when you were
young and they've been doing it ever
since and they're tired too
and they get a Bad Name all the time
so instead of of uh maligning them again
it's the same thing like go in
understand it why is it behaving why is
this part
showing up in this way and what sort of
phrase would have that's the one of the
big questions for protectors what's it
afraid would happen if it didn't do this
job and in answering that you're going
to hear either about the Exiles it
protects or about some firefighters
polarized with and it's afraid will take
over if it doesn't keep you busy writing
books or whatever right you know
no I get it and then and then there's
the uh
there's The Saboteur right so talk a
little bit about that I mean that's
that's the the the the the part that is
uh you know always undermining you uh at
just the opportune moment yeah if you
happen to have it that part we could ask
it when it's afraid would happen if it
didn't
and generally uh it's afraid you would
succeed and if you succeeded
you'd be seen and if you're seen you'd
be attacked or some version of that so
it's keeping you small let's keep you
small yeah to keep the risk the risk
level like low the stakes the stakes
being low yeah um you know one of the
things that's that's cool about all of
this is
once somebody has had experience with
sessions and sort of been you know LED
down the path of you know having an
experience with with uh yourself or or
one of the other practitioners of ifs
there's a whole sort of set of tools
that then can be practiced by the
individual itself like it becomes a very
practical kind of
habit-based tool that one can use on a
daily basis yeah
um
I said earlier it's become a kind of
Life practice so when I wake up in the
morning
I'll spend a little time in bed just
checking in with the parts that I've
been working with and seeing how they're
doing today and do they need anything
and have any of them reverted to their
past roles or
brought the burdens back or
um
and I'll just make sure they know that I
haven't forgotten about them
because for me these are real these are
not imaginary this is a real inner
family that we we all live with
and just like your external family if
you neglect them
they're gonna get extreme so there's a
ongoing it doesn't take long usually you
know maybe 10 minutes
but just uh staying connected reminding
them okay today I'm going to be doing
this interview with Rich
and I can handle it you know you guys
don't have to jump in you don't have to
you can just let me stay because it
always goes better if you let me stay
and we might even rehearse a little bit
and
so and and so when I get here and
having lunch I'm talking to them about
it's okay it's gonna be okay just let me
stay
and then I stay with those c word
qualities I'm you probably have sensed
I'm pretty calm I'm pretty confident I'm
pretty
um
clear and and compassionate and there's
like eight c words that that describe
what I'm calling self
um
creative I'm
connected
I forgot I think I just found
compassionate uh Curious
clear connected uh courageous yeah is
that eight that was the one I missed
yeah I think that's eight yeah so and
every every self in its purest State uh
those are those those eight C's kind of
uh are are prominent qualities yeah
there are other qualities like joy and
perspective and
but they don't begin with the letter c I
like you know alliteration and
these eight are the ones that are most
relevant to the healing Endeavor so
you know
um
I can check very quickly how much I'm in
my body and self versus there's some
part that's taken over
and you get a real palpable sense of the
difference
and if I feel like you know if you said
something that triggered me I would
notice and then I would just say just
just let me stay just relax a little bit
and now my parts trust that it's better
if they do that it's taking a lot of
work a lot of those morning
connections and a lot of unburdenings
but now they basically trust me most the
time yeah that's that's interesting I
think
there's something really beautiful about
the idea that the unencumbered
unadulterated you know uncompromised
pristine self that lives within all of
us
um
is characterized by all of these you
know laudable traits right like within
that there seems to be a certain
spirituality right like if all human
beings have this within them and that's
somewhat of a a natural law from your
perspective and and something that
shares and unites all of us and our path
really or our journey is to either you
know is to ReDiscover that within
ourselves and express that like I think
that's a you know there is there is a
you know a a sort of
you know non-denominational uh you know
spiritual Beauty and all of it thank you
it's true and
when I entered all this I was a
scientists non-spiritual person I come
from a theistic father and
and uh but the big challenge for me was
as I started to see self in people that
had no business any having any of those
qualities given their histories
I couldn't explain it from traditional
psychology which
believes in attachment Theory and
attachment Theory says
for you to have any of those seaward
qualities you needed to have a certain
kind of parenting during a critical
period in your childhood
and if you didn't get that then you got
to get it from a therapist you got to
get it from a spouse or it's comes from
a relationship it's not inherent in US
and I was finding people that have been
abused on a daily basis
just by getting some parts to open space
the same person would pop out in them
that was popping out in all these other
less abused clients so I couldn't
reconcile that until
people started saying well maybe this is
like Buddha nature or maybe this is like
Atman or maybe this is like Christ
Consciousness or
it seems like every spiritual tradition
has a word for it whereas almost no
other psychologies do so then I started
to say okay I can ground it over there
and it turns out you don't have to
meditate 10 years to get to it it's
right beneath the surface and of course
once you you you you create a healthy
Matrix of relationships with all of
these parts and the self can emerge and
express those eight C's not only are you
becoming a more you know fulfilled
self-actualized healthy
um human being who can contribute
positively to the world there's a whole
Downstream uh you know series of
implications to that because it ends up
obviously you're affecting all the
people that you're interacting with in a
positive way as well
yeah and as I'm getting older and uh
trying to figure out what I want as my
legacy I'm moving this to larger and
larger systems because
I think the world needs isn't just my
system but this is one of many systems
that can actually make a difference and
so
I'm trying to uh
to bring more self-leadership to the
world basically and
um and you know having some success
doing that and because I do like I said
earlier self is contagious
so for example we have we're working on
now a
training for executive coaches so that
CEOs will be more self-led and that will
just spread throughout the company and
uh and I'm working with a lot of the top
social activists in the country now
so they're not doing their activism from
righteous Parts but right martyrdom like
basically an expression of their their
pain body that's right yeah and it often
is and as we heal that those painful
parts
then they can lead from self and they
are much more effective
how does one gauge their their progress
like I've found that often it's others
who are the more reliable effective
mirrors of of one's personal growth
because on a day-to-day basis it's hard
to really know that within yourself how
does one know when they're they're
moving in the right direction or you
know is there is there
a situation in which you've arrived at
at a place of of well-being or is this
just layer after layer until you know
yeah expire
well I've been at it 40 years and I'm
still finding parts that need to be
healed but
um to answer your question
I don't get triggered like I used to by
so many things so
some of how you can judge it is
are the same things triggering me and
it's just not the case anymore
so that's one measure yeah
um there seems to be uh
a sort of anthropomorphizing of all of
these parts right like do you have
people give them names do you have them
conjure faces and personalities for them
like I'm reminded of
of I think it was Elizabeth Gilbert who
was talking about like you hear a lot of
this in the context of of creatives
going to war with their like resistance
or
um writer's block and and you know kind
of giving names to that and saying you
know Elizabeth Gilbert's example is
we're going on a road trip we're going
to drive across America and like okay
buddy you know like the the you know the
part to use your phraseology that is
telling her she's worthless and can't
write and has nothing to say and you
know blah blah blah
um
her way of explaining it was like you
can come out you're gonna come like
you're with me like we're in Partnership
right like I'm not you know like
pretending you don't exist like you're
here yeah uh but you just can't sit in
the passenger seat like you got to get
in the back seat right and uh and if you
start piping up like then I'm gonna you
know put you in the trunk or or whatever
like so there's a question trunk but
yeah yeah so it's like we come up with
all these creative ways of of saying
something sort of similar to what you're
talking about right that isn't
repressing or denying or ignoring or
compartmentalizing this aspect that
we're very aware is looming in there but
finding a way to communicate with it so
it feels heard but not empowered to you
know exert itself in a way that's going
to be damaging yeah and and she's been
using RFS for a number of years so that
that's why she talked about it that way
oh interesting oh yeah that's cool in
fact I'm going to interview her for a
thing I'm doing
I think in a week or two uh-huh
so I think so it is her yeah I think I'm
remembering that story right from yeah
yeah yeah except the trunk I don't think
she would oh maybe yeah maybe not but
but I I just do I do remember that idea
of like I'm not saying you can't come
right like you're coming yeah just shut
up or like they like you but you can't
drive we're just not gonna let you drive
right right right right right right or
maybe it was uh like you can come but
you can't like choose the songs on the
radio it could be something like that I
can't remember
um
and then of course Stephen pressfield
calls it resistance and then the flip
side is the muse and that made me think
about
um
the sort of the converse of that idea
which is adopting an alter ego to go you
know kind of do the thing right like
almost in or you put on your armaments
or your your your your your your battle
ready by you know adopting a Persona
that is kind of an extreme extrapolation
of who you are in order to go put
yourself in a challenging or difficult
situation does that mesh up with like
your model at all no that kind of
violates the spirit of it interesting
it's really to help those armored Parts
trust there is this other person in
there who can handle like three of those
eight c words are courage confidence and
clarity
so that's all you need myself can be
totally fierce
if necessary it does I don't have to
rely on an armored part
and if I'm going into a dangerous
situation
I can ask my Exiles to just go into a
kind of waiting room they don't have to
be here even
uh and let me handle this situation so
we're really trying to help these
protectors trust self and not feel like
they've got a yeah interesting because
yeah I'm wondering like so it was Kobe
Bryant who had the Mamba mentality or
David Goggins becomes Goggins and the
iron Cowboy becomes the iron cat like
they're they're they're sort of
trying to you know Channel a larger than
life version of themselves so what is
you know what is what's
wrong is the wrong word but maybe well
that's different that's different that's
kind of what I'm getting at though yeah
so
you know I played college football at my
size and so there was a part of me
that I just hated my father was full of
rage and loved running full speed into
guys twice my size and I would call on
that part and it kept me alive it kept
me from being damaged
um so in those kind of situations
where uh
it's it's fine to call on those parts
um right like an athlete who's trying to
Channel A superhuman performance yeah
unless in doing that
you're perpetuating this sense that they
don't know you and that they don't trust
you and they feel like they they have to
protect you all the time right you're
the you're the You're The Wizard of Oz
right he's behind that curtain yeah it's
like feeble and and in in in in
incontinent
compared to the alter ego right at my
age that's uh
that's not funny
um
so it's we're helping them become like
volunteer volunteer fire department
rather than firefighters that are on
duty comments right right right but
you're able to call summon them yeah
yeah yeah yeah I still have that part
when I'm now I sometimes play basketball
it can still I still like it when it
takes over sure but it doesn't have to
protect me all the time yeah
um well I think it would be cool to are
you we talked about you maybe you know
taking me through an exercise or you
would love to do that totally all right
well let's let's try this out how do we
do this
do you have something you want to
explore
um
we've talked about a bunch of different
parts of you yeah I mean I think uh you
know I've done so much work in in so
many different modalities over the years
and have grown tremendously but I still
get tripped up by
certain things that you know I feel I
beat myself up then for not being having
grown more I still uh you know I still
um driven but well I'll just give you
kind of a bunch of stuff and maybe you
can extract from that what might be
worthy of focusing on I mean I still
I've gotten a lot better but I still you
know externalize this uh you know this
sense that that my value is calibrated
to you know my accomplishments or that
you know love is is conditional as
opposed to something that I should just
be able to receive
um
you know that that no matter what I do
I'm never going to be good enough that
uh you know you should be very afraid
because it's all going to fall apart all
these stuff these things have already
I've already mentioned I think I have a
a
you know I walk around with a little bit
of a self-conscious protective shell
around me and you know on some level I'm
still the scared kid at the bus stop
that used to get to get up a little bit
that's right um and I know that you know
I've heard you do this exercise with
other people
and often
it's it starts with
um communicating to that five-year-old
version of yourself and and I was
reflecting on that a little bit and
realizing like
I don't have any memories like I don't I
don't have like I don't remember being
five like some of my earliest memories
are are much later than that yeah and
you may not have visual memory but you
may have Sensei but we just don't know
until we get in there
but so far you mentioned four or five
different protectors we could start with
so they're used to think you mentioned
the critic and then there's the striver
that's trying to get achievements so you
feel better about yourself
and then there's that shell
and there was one other I don't remember
I don't know imposter syndrome
perfectionism yeah control okay you know
I can I can keep going by the way but
like just pick one of those yeah it's
like it's that thing of like I've got a
lot I feel like I have a a pretty good
level of self-awareness around all this
stuff
um
with self-awareness by itself doesn't
sure help them change of course right
and and I did just do
um some pretty intense work around
family of origin stuff and and and so I
I feel like I'm better armed around a
lot of the childhood trauma issues and
and I've been able to
um
uh give myself a little bit more leeway
and compassion than I was able to
earlier and also
view my parents in a much more forgiving
and compassionate way because I do have
like sort of latent anger that flares up
that I think is related to that in
certain ways that still comes up from
time to time okay
all we need is a starting point so among
all those protectors
is there one you'd like to start with
I think the the
one that
um is probably the most important is
is the protector that won't let me
receive or or give love or has that
conditional relationship around around
it okay that has to do with worthiness
of course we don't have to figure it out
right now we're just going to start
by focusing on that feeling or however
you experience that protective part
and find it in your body or around your
body
yeah it's hard because there's cameras
and there's lights and I'm sitting
across from you and I'm caught up in my
head around like this is gonna this is a
public thing and you know it's like
there's a lot of layers here that maybe
might prevent me from totally being able
to may not work at all so we'll
there's no pressure and
uh I assume we can edit some of this out
sure sure places you don't want it to
um it's not so much that it's it's more
about whether I'll be able to uh against
the like I have to perform now right I
gotta be a good performer for you and
for the audience uh it's more about like
that self-consciousness of of being
watched that is preventing me from well
maybe we should start with that one why
don't we start with that self-conscious
part all right
see if you can find it in your body
around your body
I don't know I also feel my skeptic
coming up here too a little bit we
should start with that yeah
uh and I'll and I want to be a good I
understood test case I want to tell you
where it is even though I'm not sure
where it is just anything I would say in
general probably around you know my
heart all right my sternum
so focus on it there
and tell me how you feel toward it
are we still talking about the
self-conscious part or what are we
talking about
um
I think the the the worthiness of love
part is probably more at the heart of so
that's where you find him yeah and as
you notice from there how do you feel
toward him as you
Sun soon I mean there's a sense of of
there's competing
feelings on the one hand there's there's
sadness that there's this
person that feels like they're not
worthy unless they're doing things that
you know people approve of right and how
exhausting that must be totally
um and then there's the other side of it
which is
yeah but this is what makes you you and
look at all the amazing things that
you've been able to do as a result of it
this is your this is your best friend
and and your superpower yeah and you
should hold on tightly to that and it's
okay because it's okay it's okay
if you're not able to
uh
receive love because you
because
you're putting something good into the
world and that can be your legacy and
that's enough okay
so we're going to ask the part that just
said all that
to just give us a little space for
five minutes
to actually get to know this one in your
heart
and we get that it feels really
dependent on that to
do what you're doing
but let it know
and if it lets us help this one
you're not going to stop doing what
you're doing you'll just do it more
effectively I promise
I've heard that before and I don't
believe it that's fine not to believe it
but just ask if it would give us a
chance and it doesn't have to if it's if
it's too determined that this would be
too threatening to your system
but if it's willing to let us go with
compassion to this one
you can lead the system more effectively
than this part
so
I mean I can do I say that out loud
don't have to say it inside okay but if
if it's willing you'll notice a shift
and you won't have that same
need to keep it going
say it's holding on pretty tight okay
and we could shift to it
you know the one who really thinks you
have to
have this other to get anywhere
so in other words have me speak for that
part yeah okay yeah I might even I could
talk to it directly for a second if you
want sure
okay
so you're the part of Rich that really
thinks
um
he needs to feel all this bad feeling
to be motivated to do his job
and that that's enough he doesn't need
to have love in his life otherwise
because he's bringing this to the world
is that right you're that part
a little bit I I would yeah I mean I
think just let us just let it speak
don't speak yeah
so you're the person you know rich is
he's got issues let me tell you yeah
right he uh
he's he's weak he's a little too
sensitive and uh if I didn't show up you
know this guy might have not ever moved
out of the house and so I boost him
every day I get him out in the world I
get him to hustle and like look what
I've been able to manifest as a result
of that
um and uh you know just keeping him shy
of of that you know that prize that he's
reaching for uh gets him out of bed
every day okay
so I do believe you deserve a huge
amount of credit for all you just
described
all right
are you tired though
yeah am I is it the part now or is it
yourself as a part the part is
indefatigable okay I think the self is
tired just just let the part speak
though is that true that you're
you're not tired you you just could keep
going forever or are there times where
you get a little tired it's a drag but
uh I got a lot of endurance and uh
and I get uh
I get a kick out of the suffering
out of you get a kick out of Rich's
suffering yeah and what's what's the
kick about
uh
because through that suffering he uh he
learns more about himself okay so you're
afraid if he gave up the suffering he
wouldn't be learning much
the suffering is the engine
oh well that's different it's not just
learning but
he wouldn't be motivated in the way he
is without the suffering
if he's not suffering then he's not
working hard enough yeah okay
all right and how old do you think rich
is
um don't think just let it come uh
probably 15. yeah okay
so it's I get that when he was 15 you
really had to do this for him
but would it shock you to learn that
he's considerably older than that he
might think he's older than that but I
know that he's still 15. you know that
he's still 15.
and he's still as vulnerable as he was
then or what's your sense
yeah it's hard to parse the self from
the part
um just let the part spec the part uh
the part probably you know is the the
part is operating under the assumption
that nothing's changed right that he's
still in that kind of vulnerability
is that right yeah
okay so I understand why you're still
taking this position that was so
necessary back then
but if you really trusted that he wasn't
so vulnerable now
as he was then would that make a
difference in your attitude
it would but you're going to have to
prove to me that he's trustworthy yeah
so tell me more about why you think he's
not trustworthy
yes that's a that's a hard one to answer
because you don't want to disclose
something or just no no not because I
don't want to because I'm trying to
identify like if so the part
so that part
um doesn't trust you
doesn't trust me because
at 15
I had a lot of vulnerabilities and
weaknesses that were exploited that's
right by others and
and I can't see
the person the self that is operating
today that's right yeah
yeah he still lives back there he
doesn't know you he doesn't know who you
are
he still thinks you're 15 and as
vulnerable as you were
and that you couldn't protect him back
then
so
we can keep going or we can shift but if
you wanted to keep going I would ask how
you feel toward that 15 year old boy
I feel really I have deep sadness
for that like compassion sadness yeah
yeah
could you let him know that and just see
how he reacts to your compassion
there's that um
a gratitude I think just for being seen
that's right because the feeling of
being invisible totally
so let them know you get back then he
was feeling very invisible
but that you see him right now
I see him too
yeah
and that you care about him
just see if there's more he wants you to
know about what it was like back there
for
you know I think uh
a deep loneliness and
sensitivity and and feeling
feelings of of being misunderstood and
and not being heard or or recognized but
instead sort of
being uh
shouldered with
expectations that that didn't really
meet that didn't really honor or
recognize like the the person you know
yeah
so as you're getting this how are you
feeling toward him
uh if there's a
there's a there's a feeling of calm sort
of a catharsis yeah yeah
so it's really helping him to have you
witness him this way um
yeah
and do you see him right now or you just
sense them in there
now I can see him and how close would
you say you are to him in terms of feet
away
oh just you know right next to him
and how is he reacting to your proximity
I think he's uh
uh unsure
not not necessarily trusting this is new
for him
yeah
so we're not going to push this we're
just going to be with them in this
caring way
until he starts to trust a little more
in whatever way feels right to you Reg
to let him know that you he can trust
you
and just take your time
and trust you he doesn't have to perform
for you he you're just there with him
because you care about him
yeah I think that that he's comforted by
that
he's you know he's scared and uncertain
so and feels alone in that and and and
and
um and very private in that yeah
so
ask if he would like you to show up this
way for him more
than you have
there's a resistance to that yeah
from not from him from some other part
just ask
um it's more of uh you don't understand
from him yeah
so ask him about that
and where does that come from yeah
you know it's it's it's a lot of uh
it's all about like Legacy burdens
really great yeah which you talk about
yeah yeah
so what's he saying about the Legacy
burden I have to be this person okay
um I'll make it work yeah you know it'll
be fine just leave me alone so he
carries all that mm-hmm yeah
yeah and ask since he got that from
other people it's not his
does he like having to carry all that
no but it doesn't feel safe for him to
be who he wants to be in that context in
that time period is that right yeah
to ask him if he'd like you to take him
out of there
to a safe place
yeah that's what he wants okay
so are you ready to do that or is he
ready to yeah yeah
all right so let's take him could be the
president it could be to your house it
could be a fantasy place
wherever he'd like to go specifically
just ask him
I don't know that there's a specific
place other than away from where he is
so just take him just bring him here for
now all right and tell me when he's here
okay
how does he like being here
I think he's confused okay
what's he confused about well why are
there other lights and It Was 1980 a
second ago and now there's a lot of
stuff that is unrecognizable yeah that
makes sense he's confused a lot of this
didn't exist in 1980 right
okay but does he trust that he's not out
and not in that time anymore
yeah
how's that for him
relief yeah does he trust you care about
him
I think so because it was just
demonstrated yeah that's right yeah okay
just ask him though
yeah
so tell me never has to go back you're
going to be looking after him
and ask with that if he's ready to
unload this Legacy burden
that's uh made him feel so bad
I think the there is a a welcoming of
that but also
at that age the the the Legacy burden or
expectations weren't something that
that
I was fully conscious of at the time and
when is operating in my unconscious but
I wouldn't have been able to label it or
understand it so I think there's a he's
not quite understanding okay the
proposition let's let's put it this way
ask him to scan his body
and see if there's anything he carries
that doesn't belong to him
yeah there's a lot
where does he carry all that in his body
around his body
I think it's it's it's almost everything
it's a sense of of
feeling
trapped in the wrong life okay yeah
and now that he's here with you and
you're going to be taking care of him
would he like to unload that yes
all right and ask him
what he'd like to give it all up to
light water fire wind Earth anything
else
I think the water okay
so set that up take him to water
and tell him to just let all that out of
his body
off of his body let the water take it
there's no need to carry that anymore
because he's not living back there
anymore
mm-hmm
and just do that until it's all out of
him
okay
how's he feeling now
lighter yeah Freer liberated good
hopeful good
and tell them now if he wants to he can
invite qualities into his body he'd like
to have to replace all that stuff
you can just see what comes into him
yeah I think uh uh an empowering sense
of agency and
self efficacy and
permission really is a big one
that is okay for him to be who he is
that's right
so how's he doing now
I'm better yeah yeah
so now let's invite all these protectors
that we met to come in and see they
don't have to protect him anymore
there might be other parts but
that he's doing well
particularly the one that led us to him
and just see how they react
I think it's a a situation of of
like confusion like okay what are we
gonna do now but also like all right
like I guess this is this is cool he
seems like he's doing all right
well what are we going to do now is a
really good question so they can all
start thinking about new roles if they
want
what would they like to do if they
didn't have to be these these guys
a source of empowerment there you go
yeah that's right
so thank them for letting us do this is
actually quite a big piece of work yeah
yeah and uh
just check and see how it's feeling in
there if there's anything else we need
to do before we come back out
now I feel like the the reassigned roles
need to be
just providing him with not just
support and encouragement but with the
tools that he's going to need to be able
to stand on his own two feet and and
explore his own way yeah are you willing
to do that for them
so let them know
okay does that feel complete for now
yeah that was pretty good
come on out and how are you feeling
I feel good I feel good
um no it was
it was uh
surprisingly meaningful
um
I think it was a little bit
impacted by just you know the the
construct that we're in right now right
like I probably would have
been more emotional if I was sitting in
your office and no one was watching
right so I had a self-consciousness
around that I think yeah I could tell
um and also
it's just being a newer exercise of
trying to really
uh get a handle on like the parts and
how they're operating and separating
that voice from my my voice yeah yeah
given that this was your first shot at
it you're really good at it yeah
and we went to an exile that
many people takes months to get to yeah
well we'll see I mean what is the uh
what is that what's the
tail look like on this in terms of you
know how many sessions you have to do or
how do you have to like what is the you
know kind of protocol that maintain
yeah
maintenance simply means what I was
saying earlier like
tomorrow morning wake up see how this 50
year old's doing if he's still feeling
good
if not why not what happened did some
other part throw them back
um because it was threatened to not have
the power over him
uh and and so just maintaining it on
your own now
it helps to map it out in some form
but take it as you know as real right
this is a real inner system
that needs maintenance
thank you thank you yeah
um before we before we close it all down
though
um I think it would be cool if there was
some kind of like is it okay to give the
audience some type of practice I mean
you talked about what the thing that you
do in the morning but is there some kind
of takeaway
uh that they could start to wrap their
heads around and and do themselves well
the closest I can think of to that is I
did a series of these kind of things
exercises meditations for sounds true
um and I forget what it's called but
they should be able to find it all right
we'll we'll find it and link it up in
the show notes yeah and there are in the
book no bad parts I think in that book
too there are also exercises yeah yeah
all right good
um any place other than those two places
and and picking up your books
particularly the latest one that you
want to direct people towards
uh there's another book that just came
out last month called introduction to
internal family systems oddly enough
and uh it feels like that should have
been the first book yeah look these are
actually second editions of them
uh and so all that's coming out through
sounds true and
uh yeah otherwise if people go to the
website which you can post there's a
bunch of other stuff cool well I I
really appreciate the work that you do
um I know that it's been
transformational for for many people
including you know people that I'm close
to and uh
and uh I was moved by what you just took
me through so I appreciate that as well
I was honored to that you trusted me
enough to do it honestly and really
happy we could do that yeah all right
well thank you very much you're very
welcome cheers
is out